[Musique]
un travail titanesque avec des moyens
rudimentaires finalement mais il a fallu
l'amener la positionner sur le sol ça
c'était peut-être la dalle la plus
facile à mettre en œuvre
alors ça c'est un filon de quartz
qui traverse la dalle
il y a le même pilon de quartz
et ils ont fait le bandeau
graver juste en dessous
toujours en admiration devant ce travail
de la pierre ce travail de Carrié qui
est vraiment un travail de spécialiste
c'est ça tombe pas du ciel comme ça il y
a un réel savoir faire
[Musique]
donc nous sommes ici tout le nord de
Vannes tu as une espèce de alors c'est
pas une barre rocheuse mais disons que
tu as un relief comme ça qui barre un
peu l'intérieur des terres et qui est
couvert de forêt et en fait c'est une
zone que Philippe a beaucoup beaucoup
prospecté et donc très bien c'est ici
donc dans la forêt qui est autour bah il
y a on va le voir mais des il y a des
milliers isolés il y a des kernes il y a
des tumulus il y a plein de trucs et
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment en pleine
forêt donc c'est assez rigolo et là vous
vous y avez déjà été il y a 10 ans
2012-2013
[Musique]
[Rires]
tout va bien
j'ai entendu parler à midi j'entendais
parler de passer sauvage
donc du coup je vais voir je vais vous
suivez passer sauvage
on suit un peu toute la chaîne etc les
vidéos tes dernières interventions etc
connaissait la personne qui gère ça chez
Clotilde ah d'accord ok c'est rigolo
tout le monde se retourne
ici elle vient la semaine prochaine
dans la forêt je le suis tel quel
fruit parce que pour rentrer à Lyon
on comprenait pas et en fait les autres
dans la poussière du Barrière comme ça
avec écrit sodomie en gros
vous pouvez arrêter de dire un truc
dégueu sachez à chaque fois que je filme
en fait donc c'est super
[Musique]
bonsoir
il y a 7000 ans les premiers
agriculteurs néolithiques achève leur
conquête de l'Ouest
parvenu au bout du continent il couvre
le pays de monuments ces kernes et
tumulus peu à peu oubliés sont
aujourd'hui enfouis sous les arbres
et certains s'efforce de les redécouvrir
bonjour
mais c'est immense
c'est deux de car on a deux dolmens le
domaine à couloir on a encore deux
années de fouilles après celle-ci pour
finir de fouiller tout ce qui se passe
entre les deux monuments souvent les
études des pierres dressées des dolmen
et des tumulus ont été vraiment étudiés
d'une manière bien distincte alors qu'on
sait maintenant depuis peu que tout ça a
été étroitement lié la tombe qui est ici
rectangulaire les
orthostats qui sont toutes ces pierres
dressées autour le couloir d'accès avec
plusieurs murets donc voilà ça c'est la
face 1 ce qui est étonnant c'est qu'on a
trouvé à l'intérieur
une stèle
anthropomorphe
qui était tombé à l'intérieur de la
sépulture c'est à dire que le monument
ici a pu être construit avec et autour
par exemple d'une pièce maîtresse qui
est une image des peut-être une
possibilité image des ancêtres etc elle
est cachée
oui c'est cette forme pointue en
regardant de plus près 7 pointes elle a
été travaillée tout autour il y a pas de
doute sur la sur le travail de la pierre
et la mise en oeuvre de cette stèle quoi
on a enlevé la dalle la stèle
anthropomorph et on a eu la surprise de
trouver juste dessous un dépôt funéraire
composé de deux poteries néolithiques
conservés toute cette telle
anthropomorphe qui était tombée ça a été
analysé et la belle découverte c'est que
les lipides sont très bien conservées on
a des restes de produits laitiers et de
la cire d'abeille yaourt à la grecque
miel miel noix cannelle
nous échappe complètement
c'est très touchant déjà la tête
anthropomorphe en elle-même c'était très
touchant de la voir c'est vraiment que
c'est c'est rare mais ce dépôt conservé
dessous juste déposé au pied il y a le
geste symbolique et des fantastique
on fait une pause
non il y a quand même beaucoup de
travail à réaliser et puis je tape pas
trop dessus
sont souvent ou séquaires n'ont été
utilisés comme carrière par les gens du
coin et en plus il récupérait les plus
grosses dalles pour faire des linteaux
de cheminée ou de ou de porte ou de
fenêtres et du coup c'était des
carrières faciles et souvent ces
monuments ont été désossés de telle
manière que les masturbulaires les
guerres les tumulus disparaissent et
laissent apparaître tout le côté
sépulcral à l'intérieur donc voilà c'est
une mauvaise image finalement de ces
monuments qui étaient recouverts ce sont
de réels maisons des morts construites
au même titre que les maisons du vivant
avec une entrée dans une salle mortuaire
si les monuments ont servi de carrière
il y a quelques siècles ils ont aussi
été réutilisés aux périodes plus
anciennes après le néolithique ces
maisons des morts toujours visibles dans
le paysage ont inspiré les Bretons de
l'âge du bronze
quand on fait le bilan architectural des
monuments du Morbihan on s'aperçoit que
entre 20 et 70% des blocs qui
constituent ces espaces funéraires
proviennent de monuments plus anciens ou
de tel ou de d'aliments plus anciens
voilà il y a une réutilisation on ne
réappropriation de toutes ces dalles
dans ces monuments funéraires c'est
probablement pas un
hasards
mémoire dans le temps une mémoire des
ancêtres une mémoire du lieu de se
funéraire qui est assez fantastique
quand on regarde les photos que je
réalise par drone ces photos génitales
on s'aperçoit que tout le tour
de ce Caire possède des fausses il y a
vraiment une ritualisation autour de
cette sépulture néolithique mais une
ritualisation à l'âge du bronze ça monte
vraiment curieux ça va un moment que je
vois derrière nous une muraille de Chine
qui est en train de se bâtir on va
essayer de mesurer toute cette masse de
pierre qui a été déjà extraite à
l'époque néolithique qui a été mise en
place qui a été bousculée à l'âge du
Bron qui a été remobilisé par nos
fouilles et qui va être remis en place
pour reconstruction des monuments
c'est génial
on enlève 20 cm à peu près de la de la
fosse
et on détour les petites pierres du
passage à côté de la
potentiel potentielle tombe de France
il y a comme une forme ovale comme ça
c'est la texture de la terre ça
s'entraîne de voir ce genre de truc
c'est comme quand on débarque sur un
chantier faut apprendre à voir un peu
les couleurs de la terre avant de
pouvoir voir ces différentes couches
c'est vrai qu'au début pour moi c'était
ça la première semaine je comprenais pas
tout mais bon à force de demander et de
et d'observer parce que il suffit de
gratter un petit peu et on peut voir on
peut sentir la différence de texture de
la terre là-bas par exemple ce qu'on
cherche c'est de la reine granitique et
puis on sent tout de suite on l'a suivi
[Musique]
incroyable
j'avais vraiment raison c'est très c'est
vraiment très bon que délicieux
[Musique]
son de la stèle jour 2
cette stèle ici est implantée dans une
fosse donc elle est en place et la
surprise on regardant un petit peu de
loin c'est de voir qu'il y avait un
travail de la pierre on voit assez
nettement je pense
ce premier rond ici et un deuxième qui
est en partie en partie cassée est-ce
que ce sont des yeux est-ce que c'est
une symbolise d'une paire de seins on
sait pas trop c'est pas facile de voir
et là on voit aussi tout ce travail en
chevrons pour donner un petit peu cette
chevelure ou autre chose dans la partie
supérieure et ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est à ce niveau là on a un
bandeau et on voit deux lignes ici et
avec ce comme ceinturon cette voilà de
boucle de ceinture ou à moins que ça
soit autre chose une couleur un peu
rouge toujours est-il que on a là je
pense une des sols si je ne me trompe
genre de statue menhir protohistorique
c'est
c'est pas une pierre tombale
c'est la grosse question à quoi ils ont
pu servir servir là elle est vraiment
dans un contexte funéraire que ça soit
néolithique ou de l'âge du bronze après
cette structure est-ce qu'il renfermait
un corps ou pas ça c'est difficile de
savoir on fera des analyses chimiques
pour voir le taux de phosphore on aura
une réponse à ce niveau-là
ça indique la présence d'un corps ou de
plusieurs corps
je fais des photos pour une
photogrammétrie
disons que je multiplie toutes les
photos
et après tout ça ça va aller dans un
logiciel qui va reconstituer le site il
va transformer ses photos et un nuage de
points
à partir de ce nuage de points il y aura
un maillage de fait et tu obtiens une
modélisation 3D de l'ensemble
et ça permet de figer un état de fouille
un instant x donc du coup avant de
descendre un peu plus bas faut figer ça
numériquement faut absolument pas de
grosses différences de luminosité sinon
le logiciel il comprend pas et il prend
en charge qu'une partie des photos donc
il faut se lever tôt
vous se coucher tard
des fois je fais les deux
c'était une masse mélangée de pierre et
de et de limon assez incompréhensible au
départ et c'est vrai qu'on commence à
voir les les solutions de
lecture c'est vrai que c'est un long
travail
et c'est gratter la arraché les cheveux
pendant plus d'une fois c'est plein de
petits impacts tu vois regarde avec le
soleil
et tu regardes le dessous de celle là
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup plus brut et celle-ci
latin très bel exemple
et une analyse technologique de bloc
c'est tant que ça c'est des encoches de
débitage des dalles en carrière et ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle une dia class une
faille naturelle du granite du coup pour
extraire ce bloc là tu as vu la grandeur
du bloc il faisait des encoches dans les
fissures pour rien serrer probablement
je pense du bois dur et ils arrivaient
avec des leviers à décoller et enlever
la dalle tu en as une là
tu dois en avoir d'autres ailleurs on
peut
une sur l'autre bloc là
juste non tout ça sur le bord extérieur
les Allemands
encore une autre et tu fais le tour de
la dalle on va trouver tous les endroits
où ils sont intervenus donc ils ont
cherché un endroit où il pouvait enlever
des grosses dalles comme ça pour en
faire à la fois la dalle de sol et à la
fois la dalle de couverture c'est un
travail de
fou travailler la pierre mais avec quoi
comme matière et percuteur en parts
probablement c'est la matière le
matériau le plus dur qu'il existe dans
le secteur géographique c'est qu'ils
avaient des petits des groupes
percuteurs et voilà par impact successif
sur la pierre le granite finalement
finit par s'éclater en surface et ils
arrivent à régulariser une surface alors
on peut même voir d'ailleurs que ces
impacts sont plus grossiers
ici par exemple que cette partie là
le percuteur était peut-être plus petit
c'est ça qu'il faut regarder avec
précision après
c'est pas un rond mais toute cette zone
ici la percussion est beaucoup plus fine
on peut pas considérer ça comme une
simple dalle qui a été retirée et
transportée et posée il y a tout le
travail en amont et en aval de mise en
forme de la dalle du surfaçage et la
mise en oeuvre donc c'est pas rien quand
même quoi quand on voit les l'épaisseur
les volumes et le poids des dalles de
couverture qui reposait sur cette masse
là ça ne bougait pas d'un centimètre
mais la dalle reposait sur ses
constructions il fallait que ça tienne
dans le temps et c'est vraiment
calculé quoi c'est un travail de haute
technologie on a rien inventé quoi c'est
ça ne bouge pas d'un centimètre je pense
qu'il y avait des maçons vraiment
spécialisés et la dalle de couverture
devait à peu près cet auteur là ici il y
a une pierre dressée qui est cassée mais
qui est en place
et derrière toi Lucas on a encore une
pierre dressée qui était décapitée et
qui est encore en place juste à l'entrée
du monument ce sont des détails
architecturaux très importants parce que
moi je me pose la question s'il y avait
pas ici avec ces trois dalles un petit
alignement de Pierre dressé bien
antérieur d'accord à cet ensemble
ça veut dire que c'est probablement des
familles privilégiées
à haute valeur sociale ajoutée qui était
inhumée dans ces monuments ces
structures familiales ont pu être
regroupés à un moment donné et
enfouie sous un immense tumulus allongé
de type Barnenez ou des grands tumulus
de tissu a pris c'est la Charrière dans
les Deux-Sèvres malgré nos destructions
récentes c'est quand même des monuments
qu'on pratiquement 6 millions
d'existence parce que tu es plus ému par
des découvertes à l'échelle de l'être
humain en général genre à cette époque
tiens les humains étaient comme ça
faisait ce type de rythme chose comme ça
ou des choses plus intimes de
tel moment telle personne à déposer du
lait du miel je peux pas dire que quand
on a trouvé les poteries là je mets
c'était vraiment
trois jours avant la fin de la fouille
et là c'est vraiment une grosse émotion
du coup on s'est assis là on a regardé
ça des heures après c'était exceptionnel
après bon on ne pouvait pas
effectivement les laisser en place il a
fallu
dégager les poteries prendre toutes les
mesures conservatoires possibles mais
c'est vrai que toutes les tous les
bénévoles qui ont participé à cette
découverte et qui chacun les uns après
les autres ont travaillé un petit peu
sur les poteries ça a été une émotion
assez assez incroyable comme si elle
venait d'être posée
ée
puis c'est l'émotion de Philippe qui a
été sympa enfin voilà je te dis que
c'est aussi bah c'est son projet soit tu
participes tu viens gratter tu viens
aider à sortir de la terre des sous et
des cailloux mais pour lui
sur ce sujet là tu auras du mal à faire
la différence ça demande de se
concentrer un petit peu et une
différence de résistance de couleur de
granulométrie pas du tout pareil
et ben merci
moi je ne sais pas quoi se trouve
sérieux et après on va attaquer le
couloir aussi il y a peut-être quelques
détails d'architecturaux intéressants
aussi
on était à la mairie
[Musique]
quand c'est pas fouillé dans la forêt et
encore cela ils sont un petit peu plus
haut
donc voilà un petit peu l'aspect je
dirais naturel des découvertes si on
fouillait ça on trouverait un deux trois
par mois etc etc il est probable c'est
une mobilière que logique sont encore
présents à l'intérieur des monuments qui
ont jamais été fouillés si on attaqué
celui-là
on coupe les arbres c'est comme ça qu'on
a procédé pour l'autre et après on a
décapé toutes ces couches du musc de
feuilles de racines et ensuite on
attaque la masse musculaire pour essayer
de retrouver la forme globale du
monument ça veut dire c'est une chambre
sépulcrale gigantesque rectangulaire et
le couloir d'accès et sous le preneur de
son on va dire on m'a dit qu'il y avait
de l'or donc je suis venu
du coup on va laisser les étudiants
partir on va discuter en tête-à-tête
bon c'est des monuments qui sont trop
bien conservés enfin celui-là est trop
bien conservé pour être fouillé celui-là
pourrait être fouillé parce qu'il est
vraiment bien démoli mais des monuments
comme ça il y en a quand même pas mal
dans le secteur pourquoi vous prenez
automatiquement les monuments qui sont
les moins bien conservés en sachant que
les mieux conservés pour avoir plus de
c'est des directives des services de
l'État finalement toute l'ossature et
toute l'histoire du monument est
présente sur 40-50 cm d'épaisseur un
monument bien conservé évidemment on
aura plus de masse musculaire mais c'est
pas forcément ça qui va nous apporter
plus de réponses à nos questionnements
[Musique]
Clotilde j'espère que tu regardes cette
vidéo en entier
je suis complètement paumé
mais là je
j'ai vu que je filme en même temps ça
n'aide pas
Square
[Rires]
je peux voir vos têtes ça me pose pas de
problème de toute façon
foutu pour foutu la photo est
dégueulasse
je te vois j'ai vu ce que tu as fait
ok on pose
on parlait un petit peu de d'émotion ça
a l'air de rien c'est vrai que tout le
monde se mobilise pour enlever cette
stèle ça s'est pas trop mal passé là on
enlève quand même de son lieu d'origine
une telle anthropomorphe qui est qui
avait une haute valeur symbolique pour
la période du Bronze voilà c'est
l'archéologie comment on dit mais bon
moi je suis pas insensible à ça quoi on
se pompe funéraire il y a des adultes
mais il y a également des enfants des
immatures etc et ben tu sais pas ce qui
s'est passé c'est des maladies des
accidents des des luttes de territoire
empêche que tous ces gens sont là et
c'est vrai que quand tu accèdes à ces
niveaux d'information ça prend des
tripes c'est peut pas rester insensible
par rapport à ça mais voilà la stèle
c'est ça les poteries c'est ça Twitter
aussi c'est à dire que c'est quelque
chose qui prend du temps donc tu as un
rapport ou tu es penché dessus pendant
des heures voir des jours tu as il y a
presque une intimité qui se crée aussi
c'est pas juste tu fais une photo et
puis ah non non pas un rapport physique
avec avec ce que tu es en train de
découvrir donc il y a aussi ça passe
aussi par là quoi vous vous sentez
capable d'aller jusqu'au véhicules on
fait des pauses
[Musique]
porteur de rondin déplacement de rondin
calage de rondin déplacement des rondins
[Musique]
il faut faire une pause on fait une
pause
on refait le monde
un petit blanc
et voilà la boîte se remettre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
histoire de Lyon et de sa relation très
étroite en fait avec l'armée puisque la
vie est fondée par un général romain de
César il y a la présence de cette
fameuse coordurbaine et des événements
militaires comme l'année 69 la bataille
de Lyon 297 après Jésus-Christ ma copine
de Fourvière elle est occupée on va dire
par la ville romaine on estime à peu
près jusqu'à la fin du troisième siècle
après Jésus-Christ le site ici est pillé
par les troupes de Septime on a ce crâne
de légionnaires décapité qu'on avait
trouvé l'année précédente qui était une
belle découverte pour me faire montrer
cette scène violente de destruction du
camp et au lieu de transformer ce
secteur qui est quand même un secteur
qui devait être très grand le site est
littéralement détruit les murs sont
effondrés on vient le remblayer et après
il y a plus rien qui se passe ici
[Musique]